muy buenas tardes pues efectivamente hoy
era la posibilidad para los 14 acusados
allí presentes de dirigirse ante la
corte para por última vez el último en
hacerlo fue sala abdeslam a quien una
vez más presentó sus excusas a las
víctimas a los familiares también de las
víctimas allí presentes y dijo pues que
en realidad él sabía que no era un
hombre perfecto que había cometido
muchos errores pero que él no era un
asesino que él no había matado a nadie
que en caso de que se le condenara por
eso pues simplemente iba a cometer se
una gran injusticia todo eso teniendo en
cuenta que la fiscalía antiterrorista
francesa pidió el cadena perpetua para
xala abdeslam una cadena perpetua de
masa irreductible los demás acusados
también hicieron uso de esa posibilidad
de dirigirse a la corte uno de ellos no
quiso pero la mayoría pues dijeron que
tenían confianza en la justicia francesa
en que iba a ser una decisión justa o
uno de ellos que sí dijo que tenía mucho
miedo de que se fuera a tomar una
decisión incorrecta contra él y otro de
ellos
jiang hacia los últimos momentos de esta
audiencia dijo que se levantaba todos
los días con muchísimo remordimiento por
lo sucedido y que él quizás hubiera
podido hacer algo para evitarlo para
evitar estos atentados terroristas en
todo caso bueno pues ya nos queda
esperar el veredicto ya están en
deliberación y este veredicto lo
conoceremos en la tarde de este próximo
miércoles